úgy érezheti az illető polgár minthogyha
egy hivatali ügyintéző az anya nyelvén
beszélne vele ráadásul ennek van egy
másik
óriási előnye hogy ugye nagyon nagyon
sokan sajnos funkcionálisan alfabéták
nem csak indiában nállunk is
és és ugye ezeknek az embereknek pedig
megint csak óriási segítség hogy nem egy
ilyen jogi bükfanyelven megfogalmazott
űrlapot kell kit tölteni hanem
elbeszélget egy ilyen
chatbottal azért ugye a ha facebook
messengeren tud valaki beszélgetni akkor
valószínűleg a chatbottal is fog tudni
beszélgetni és akkor így így eljutunk
oda hogy
akkor azon a nyelven kigenerálódik a
kitöltött űrlap amin az adott hivatalnak
az kell de a az az illető az anyanyelvén
kommunikálhatott a a a chatbottal és én
úgy gondolom hogy ez óriási segítség
lenne nekünk erdélyi magyaroknak
is és és nem csak az egész unió
területén ez egy ez egy hihetetlenül
fontos dolog
lenne részben ugye a a a nemzeti
kisebbségek számára de de akkor is
hogyha valakinek az anyanyelve az
államnyelve akkor is segíthet